well you may not realize it but nevada
is one of the most seismically active
states in the nation behind california
and alaska and that's why it's so
important to know how to prepare for an
earthquake and what to do to stay safe
during one kate houston is live this
morning to explain the earthquake drills
going on today and why it is crucial for
our area i would imagine for people of
all ages right kate
yes that's right sherry all ages need to
know what to do if an earthquake happens
and today is the great shakeout that's
when businesses schools and families are
going to be going through some of those
earthquake drills now some of the most
common injuries can happen from falling
objects from breaking glass so the best
thing you can do if you're indoors is
get underneath a heavy object like a
table a desk you're going to want to
fully get your body underneath it cover
your head and hold on for safety
more than 380 thousand people in clark
county are registered to participate in
the great nevada shakeout clark county
is earthquake country and residents need
to be prepared locally there are several
earthquake faults and were next to major
fault lines in california and utah the
great shakeout officials say there is
concern the las vegas basin can trap
seismic waves from major earthquakes and
cause shaking to last longer because of
this residents should have a safety plan
in place before during and after an
earthquake shelves should be fastened
securely to walls and heavy objects
should not be hung over beds or couches
during an earthquake hide under
furniture like a desk and stay away from
windows to avoid shattering glass
afterwards expect after shocks and stay
out of damaged areas
well the most recent earthquake happened
about two weeks ago in summerlin it was
1.5 magnitude so not too big but the
great shakeout drills will be happening
this morning at 10 21 a.m